Here's sort of the last thing.
I guess I'm kind of done with
solution concepts, right?
So I said that we've
done Nash Equilibrium.
We did Subgame Perfect.
We have now done Correlated Equilibrium,
and
we're not going to talk about
any of these other things.
So I guess we're done.
>> I was really hoping that we would
talk about at least the Coco thing.
I think we said in a summary that
there's more to say about that.
>> Well there's more to say
about everything, Michael.
But that doesn't mean
that we have to say it.
Just because we can do something
it does not follow that we should.
>> So but, I mean, Coco is interesting
in some of the same ways that
Correlated Equilibrium
are interested in.
Sort of sort of goes a little
bit beyond it in some ways.
I feel like it would kind of round
out the story really nicely.
>> Okay, well, you know I'm a big
fan of story rounding-outing.
So
>> [LAUGH] With TD TD MDT.
>> I am more than happy
to let you do that.
Would you like to?
>> Sure!
Yeah, I can do that.
>> Okay, well then, here's the pen.
>> Great, so if you just don't mind.
Wait, no, aah!
[BEEP] Great,
now I will take it from there.